THAT THE MEDIA IGNORED FOR
DECADES, THE REAL FOREIGN
INFLUENCE SCANDAL.
AND IF THAT IS THE CASE,
GOD BLESS THEM.
FOX NEWS POLITICAL ANALYST JOINS
US TONIGHT.
>> HI, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF A ANOTHER
INDICTMENT FOR LYING?
SPEAK OF THE FIRST THING THAT
STRUCK ME ABOUT IT WAS THAT THIS
MAN IS ACCUSED OF A CRIME THAT
HAPPENED DURING THE COURSE OF
THE INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS TO S
THE INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS TO Y
THE INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS TO N
THE INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS TO O
INVESTIGATION, NO CRIME.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY TYPICAL OF
WHAT WE HAVE A SPECIAL COUNSEL
AND INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY END UP AS OFTEN AS NOT
BEING AFTER PEOPLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE
INVESTIGATION AND NOT SO MUCH
FOR THE EVENT OR THE CRIME OR
THE ISSUE FOR WHICH THE
INVESTIGATION WAS STARTED IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
AND THAT IS WHERE WE ARE HERE IN
THIS CASE.
THAT IS ALSO TRUE OF THE
PAPADOPOULOS INDICTMENT.
AND ALSO LIKEWISE TRUE THAT TO
THE PAUL MANAFORT AND ASSOCIATED
CHARGES WERE ABOUT THINGS THAT
HAPPENED BEFORE THE CAMPAIGN,
WHICH WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
PRINCIPAL SUBJECT EVENTS DURING
THE CAMPAIGN AND THE PRINCIPAL
OF THE INVESTIGATION, AS HE
POINTED OUT EARLIER, TUCKER, WE
ARE READY FOR HERE FROM THE
ORIGINAL PURPOSE OF THE
INVESTIGATION, WHICH IF YOU ARE
RIGHT, MAY BE A GOOD THING.
BUT IT IS ALSO GIVING YOU AN
IDEA OF WHAT A WIDE-RANGING AND
LARGELY UNACCOUNTABLE FORCE A
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
CAN BE.
>> Tucker: IMAGINE IF MUELLER
DECIDED IN THE COURSE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION TO BROADEN HIS AIM
TO UNCOVER THE EXTENSIVE WEB OF
FOREIGN INFLUENCE ON OUR POLICY,
NOT OUR ELECTIONS, BUT HOW WE
MAKE LAWS AND TRADE DEALS
ET CETERA.
YOU KNOW FROM SPENDING YOUR LIFE
HERE THAT IT IS EXTENSIVE.
THAT WOULD BE IN AN ENORMOUS
INVESTIGATION, WOULD IT NOT BE?
>> IT WOULD BE AN ENORMOUS
INVESTIGATION.
I'M NOT SURE THAT I AGREE WITH
YOU ABOUT TO THE EXTENT OF THE
INFLUENCE.
IT SEEMS LIKE LOOKING THROUGH
THE RUNOFFS THAT I HAVE SEEN
THROUGH THE MILITARY
INVESTIGATION AND MAJOR POLICY
CHANGES THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
WIDELY DEBATED IN MOST CASES AND
I AM THINKING ABOUT THE DEBATES
THAT I WITNESSED ON THE FLOOR OF
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE ABOUT
THESE MATTERS.
I AM MUST SAY TO YOU, TUCKER,
MAYBE I'M BLIND, BUT I DO NOT
REMEMBER THE DARK INFLUENCES ON
SENATORS I SAW.
I WATCH THEM DEBATE THE MAIN
ELEMENTS THAT YOU WOULD EXPECT
TO BE SPOKEN OF IN THE COURSE --
>> Tucker: BUT YOU CAN SEE
THIS, EVERYONE WHO LIVES HERE
KNOW THAT A TON OF PEOPLE, A
LEGITIMATELY A LOT OF PEOPLE
TAKING MONEY FROM FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS TO INFLUENCE OUR
POLICY.
THAT IS NOT AN UNUSUAL THING TO
DO FOR A LIVING HERE.
>> IT IS CERTAINLY TRUE THAT A
LAW FIRMS AND LOBBYING FIRMS
THAT DO BUSINESS IN WASHINGTON
ARE OFTEN HIRED BY FOREIGN
CLIENTS AND FOREIGN INTERESTS.
THAT IS NO PARTICULAR MYSTERY.
AND THAT IS OUT IN THE OPEN.
THE QUESTION THAT I THINK THAT
IT RAISES IS HOW REALLY
INFLUENTIAL ARE THEY?
AND BASED ON WHAT I HAVE
WITNESSED, I'M NOT SURE THAT
THEY ARE TERRIBLY INFLUENTIAL.
I MIGHT ADD TO THAT THAT
SPEAKING ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE
NOT TERRIBLY INFLUENTIAL, YOU
CAN LOOK AT THE CHARGES THAT
MUELLER HAS BROUGHT TO THE CASE
ABOUT THE 13 INDICTMENTS OF
RUSSIAN INDIVIDUALS THAT CAME
OUT LAST WEEK IT DOES NOT ADD UP
TO VERY MUCH, NOT VERY MUCH
MONEY AND NOT AS WE CAN TELL
VERY MUCH INFLUENCE.
AND OF COURSE THESE ARE 13
INDIVIDUALS WHO ALMOST WILL
NEVER BE PROSECUTED.
THEY ARE RUSSIANS AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN WILL NOT BE